[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
numéro de si on parlait sport spécial
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2020 24
on va parler bien sûr pendant une heure
de toutes les thématiques qui concernent
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
puis particulièrement de l'actualité
dans les Yvelines aux invités sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique s'il vous plaît on commence à ma
droite il est toujours très élégant il
est conseillé spécial sur les Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique 2024 à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il est aussi
fan de golf et de course à pied Mister
Jo Arnaud courtier est avec nous pendant
une heure comment allez-vous
un petit peu l'émission j'ai tout bien
préparé j'ai bien travaillé comme
d'habitude
tous les jours si je peux dire c'est ça
on peut dire ça on continue notre tour
de table à gauche musique son entreprise
est présente dans le monde entier il
couvre des Jeux Olympiques et Jeux
olympiques depuis
1992 12 et il adore ça il nous vient
tout droit de Coignières sont surnom
Spider-Man car ils tissent des câbles
dans tous les stades pas avec ces
caméras Benoît Danton de xdmotion ou
bien tout droit de Coignières il est
avec nous sur ce plateau bonjour Michael
bonjour à tous Comment allez-vous bah
formidable très bien les JO ça vous
parle forcément on est en plein dedans
on a commencé déjà oui depuis 1992 j'ai
regardé
sur le tremplin de Courchevel et alors
ça m'entend plus sensible on a démarré
dans les Yvelines déjà avec le château
de Versailles on a commencé et puis on a
fait les premières perrages sur le golf
déjà aujourd'hui et puis quelques tests
BMX et puis on a juste sorti les les les
Mondiaux au Vélodrome donc ça va vous
portez bien
il y a une grosse pression et une grosse
pression qui démarre on repasse de
l'autre côté musique c'est un président
exceptionnel il est le président de
l'une des équipes les plus compétitives
d'Île-de-France avec de nombreux
champions le nom de son équipe
vous sert il adore le cyclisme mais il
s'intéresse à tous les sports mr
President Thierry Fabre est avec nous
mais respect Michaël bonjour à tous les
amis comment allez-vous très bien merci
de nous avoir invité aujourd'hui pour
parler sport vraiment sport pour une
fois c'est exceptionnel
tremplin de Tokyo avec Florian Grandvaux
médaillé de bronze de vitesse par équipe
direction les JO Paris avec quelques
chinois dernière ligne droite avant les
jointes encore un petit peu de temps il
faut se préparer on continue de l'autre
côté musique il a participé aux Jeux
paralympiques d'Athènes en tennis il a
gagné le tournoi de New York en 2003 en
simple et en double sur le court central
de Flushing meadow il nous vient tout
droit de Montigny-le-Bretonneux Régis
arène ou fait l'honneur de venir dans
cette émission bonjour Michael bonjour à
tous Comment allez-vous Régis très bien
bon les Mondiaux qui sont déroulés à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux j'imagine que
vous avez suivi les Mondiaux
aussi c'était grandiose un un très grand
nombre et les Giroux les attendaient
évidemment bien sûr les ai vécu de
l'intérieur maintenant
vous avez donné peut-être des conseils
peut-être pour l'organisation
on termine de l'autre côté musique qui
nous vient aussi de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est bénévoles
sur les grands événements internationaux
il adore aussi le sport et notamment le
handball il est toujours de bonne humeur
Patrick Cheb est avec nous pendant une
heure bonjour à tous vous êtes de bonne
humeur aujourd'hui
comment allez-vous du coup
on est bien occupé avec les opérations
de bénévolat sur ce qui se passe à
Saint-Quentin donc c'est ce que ça fait
partie de nos missions d'émission de
l'association et vous étiez aussi sur
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste
bénévoles sur les mondiaux et on a passé
beaucoup de temps alors avant de passer
au programme de l'émission spéciale Jo
on va parler de la nouvelle de la
semaine elle est elles ont été dévoilées
par le comité d'organisation
des jeux les friches seront les
mascottes des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 comme leur
nom l'indique qu'elles sont inspirées du
bonnet phrygien symbole de la révolution
et de la République française la
mascotte a été testée et validée par des
échantillons d'enfants de 6 à 14 ans le
kogap espère écoulé 2 millions
d'exemplaires des frites jusqu'au Jeux
olympiques de 2024 est-ce que vous
validez cette mascotte messieurs oui ou
non vous avez des petits raquettes vert
pour oui rouge pour non vous êtes
partagé vous Patrick Chab non non ver
d'accord
donc tout le monde est unanime sur la
question je dois vous donner la parole
peut-être Arnaud
elles sont jolies elles sont
sympathiques c'est la même mascotte
presque la même mascotte pour les Jeux
Olympiques et les Jeux paralympiques le
symbole est fort
elles sont asexuées finalement c'est
Mascott et tout le monde peut s'y
approprier
j'espère qu'au-delà des petites peluches
qu'on a déjà vu ils vont nous faire des
des vrais bonnets mascottes qu'on va
pouvoir porter pendant les jeux non
elles sont moi je trouve très réussi
vraiment vous avez en acheter bien sûr
moi j'ai un bon souvenir en Chine
d'avoir fait la queue pour acheter ma
mascotte pendant des heures et des
heures et des heures parce que il y
avait une rupture de stock total sur les
mascottes là-bas et c'est vrai qu'elle
était relativement sympa aussi en Chine
et là j'avoue que j'étais agréablement
surpris j'en ai vu beaucoup et là
effectivement je la trouve très sympa
simple et d'un visuel très agréable les
plus belles ou pas que vous avez pu voir
vous êtes sur les JO depuis 1992 tu vas
reconnaître qu'elle se ressemblait
toutes sur toutes les années que c'est
souvent sans plus tard
il y a une réelle déjà multicolore comme
vous voulez voir là sur les sur les
anciennes il y avait il y avait
effectivement sur la Chine
cosmonaute avec un masque scaphandre
retour qui était assez sympa et original
que vous avez fait la queue c'était
sympa pour amener mes enfants et là
j'avoue que
moi je trouve qu'elles ont une vraie
identité effectivement
pas savoir faire la française on va dire
ça comme ça Régis convaincu aussi dans
cette frise
de 2024 2004 pardon
on va faire donc en tant qu'athlète on
avait le droit on a tous eu droit à une
petite mascotte non c'était un bon
souvenir et puis là le fait que l'image
cotes se ressemblent et tout et soit à
peu près identiques avec une petite
différence une petite subtilité avec la
prothèse je trouve ça assez subtile
Patrick
parce que c'est elles sont bien elles
sont présentes sont sympas et puis
effectivement
le petit détail qui fait la différence
dans tout domaine c'est bien Thierry
elles sont historique
historique et puis histoire à venir
c'est un bon rapport pour les jeunesse
c'est ça qui est important
d'exemplaires sur un chiffre qui vous
pari cohérent à Arnaud
cohérent mais bas oui quand on sait
qu'on attend 11 millions de spectateurs
à Paris pour les jeux je pense qu'ils
peuvent en vendre plus peut-être qu'ils
ont mis un chiffre assez bas et pour
après exploser les peut-être
première vente pour les vendre moins
cher et vendre plus faire après c'est
une stratégie de commercial commercial
peut-être alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous vous parlerons des
bénévoles qui sont en présence sur ces
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024
nous serons d'ailleurs présents sur ces
JO enfin vous serez présent sur ces JO
Patrick Chihab en tant que bénévole vous
avez déjà votre petit ticket je crois
c'est je suis dans le couloir dans le
dernier dans la dernière ligne droite
et on parlera également du Marathon de
Paris de des JO de 2024 qui passera par
les Yvelines mais avant de parler de
cette thématique on va parler des
mondiaux sur piste
[Musique]
c'était le moment fort de ce mois
d'octobre dans les Yvelines je veux bien
sûr parler des Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste ils étaient organisés
du 12 au 16 octobre au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
une vraie répétition générale avant les
Jeux olympiques de 2024 sur la piste les
Tricolores sont sont plutôt bien sortis
avec trois médailles d'or 3 médailles
d'argent et une médaille de bronze dans
les tribunes le vélodrum a attiré plus
de 20
000 spectateurs dans le vélo Drôme et de
nombreux étrangers on va pas se mentir à
mon avis bref une ambiance
exceptionnelle la question sur cette
thématique est-ce que c'est mondiaux sur
piste sont un test grandeur nature
réussi oui ou non vous votez
totalement réussi totalement réussi
non pour vous Thierry alors on va faire
un petit duel je sais pas entre vous
Régis et Thierry alors Thierry pourquoi
vous êtes seul contre tous mais pour
l'accueil des personnes handicapées
ça j'ai comme vous avez tous une section
au sport chez nous et puis j'avais
dépassé handicapé
et le système de surveillance et
sécurité là étaient pas armés pour
pouvoir nous accueillir avec
un passage au niveau des médias où il y
avait des passerelles et là je veux
faire un grand tour porter des fauteuils
pour accéder au tribunes c'est le seul
point négatif puis qui a été bien
corrigé par la FFC par Nicolas André qui
était présent il y a eu beaucoup de
réactivité et on s'est dit en commun
c'est pas bien quand ça arrive comme ça
ça devrait jamais arriver jamais mais
c'est une solution un problème qu'on
n'aura pas en 2024
ça a été le point négatif et je ne sais
pas si toi tu es ressenti moi je suis
arrivé un peu tard dans les Mondiaux je
suis pas je suis pas allé le premier
jour donc ça s'est passé le premier jour
les premiers jours et après moi quand je
suis venu j'ai pas eu de souci en fait
donc j'ai pas été contre moi ce que ce
qui m'a plu c'est l'ambiance après on
parlera des parabellos parce que c'était
pas la même chose là on sera négatif je
serai négatif parce qu'il y a eu plein
de choses la communication était
extrêmement mauvaises donc c'est le
point le point noir qui a été ensuite
réfléchi mais je dirais que c'est c'est
un mal pour un bien quelque part parce
que comme ça les erreurs vont pas être
heureux refaites et il y a que en fin de
compte et les championnats du monde
c'est une grande manœuvre nature en
direct pour tout le monde
même site même endroit parce que Arnaud
tu en penses je pense que donc on peut
dire que c'est parfaitement réussi
puisque dès le premier jour on a pu
trouver un point d'amélioration et qu'il
a pu être corrigé donc au moins pour
2024 sur plus d'erreurs
pour l'ambiance extraordinaire
extraordinaire non c'est par contre on
peut peut-être revenir sur un point
quand même il y a quand même un petit
point sur les parkings qui ont été sous
dimensionnés mais ça c'est la structure
même du Vélodrome parce que moi j'ai
fait partie de
l'homologation de ce vélodrome et on
avait justement souligné ce point là qui
était qui est un point un peu négatif
parce que et ça ça a jamais été corrigé
c'est la problématique du site c'est le
choix fait sa construction de
privilégier les accès en transport en
commun pour les spectateurs d'avoir très
peu de parkings sur site il est vrai que
en mode grand événement international ça
n'est pas sans poser certains problèmes
logistiques pour les différents accès
nécessaires à proximité et évidemment
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est nécessité et quand on ajoute à ça
les besoins logistiques la presse etc ça
coince un petit peu
Benoît qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors Régis conquis Thierry a conquis
sur
exactement
parce que vous étiez en hauteur et en
fait on regarde très peu la compétition
contrairement ce qu'on pourrait croire
on est vraiment concentré sur le
l'ambiance et ce qui se passe au niveau
des des sportifs mais d'un point de vue
caméra spéciale donc là on avait en plus
une grosse expérimentation avec Nokia et
orange et une dizaine de partenaires
sous l'égide de de Saint-Quentin et
c'est vrai que on avait on a fait une
innovation absolument incroyable il faut
savoir que Obs qui représente le CIO au
niveau audiovisuel et s'est déplacé ils
ont été très impressionnés par la
démonstration alors déjà par la
compétition elle-même mais aussi par les
moyens techniques puisqu'on a réussi à
faire des transmissions de très très
hautes résolutions en 36 360 degrés avec
des caméras aériennes cablecam etc
j'avoue que j'avais jamais fait ça et
dans le monde je crois que ça s'était
jamais fait à ce niveau là avec une
transmission en 5G qui a permis de
tester de valider et on va recommencer
le 26 novembre sur le prochain événement
le troisième round de Lucie trac avec
cette technologie là pour faire nos
derniers tests donc pour moi ça a été un
moment très fort et je crois assez
historique sur la technologie qu'on a
déployé tous ensemble après presque deux
ans de préparation quand même et six
mois d'essai de test avec une forte
pression derrière sur les sur Paris 2024
et tout a bien fonctionné non pas du
tout et c'est c'est de test grandeur
nature finalement le nom d'une
expérimentation et c'est ce qu'on
souhaite et en fait on s'est rendu
compte pour des petites anecdotes il y a
beaucoup de coachs sportifs qui viennent
avec des cartons Amazon avec des des
wifi absolument pas homologués alors
donc ils arrivent et puis ils arrosent
conséquences comme ils le souhaitent
comme s'ils étaient dans n'importe quel
pays du monde et en fait on se retrouve
complètement pollué par ce type donc
c'était très bien pour la recette qui a
justement commandité cette cette
expérimentation aussi d'origine de se
rendre compte que il fallait aussi en
tant que organisateur de ce test faire
un petit peu la police pour justement
que c'est fréquences soient
véritablement cernées et validé donc on
a eu pas mal de soucis liés à cette
problématique là par contre on a on a
quand même eu de très très beaux
résultats avec des des immersions
absolument incroyables je sais pas si
vous avez pu vous rendre et elle va
certainement mais faire le test chez les
différents partenaires dans l'attente
Nokia mais c'était voilà c'était assez
sympathique et puis surtout on était pas
dans le vélodrome mais en s'y sentait
absolument
dans la même ambiance et c'est ça
l'objectif
moi j'ai été ravi voilà vraiment
franchement j'étais ravi par l'ambiance
je crois que tous les spectateurs qui
étaient présents il y a une ambiance
folle et pas voilà pour tous les pays
d'ailleurs c'est l'expérience pour vous
aussi Arnaud
et c'est pour ça que j'insiste sur le
fait que ce sont des Mondiaux réussi ils
sont réussis pour les spectateurs pour
les téléspectateurs pour les athlètes
après nous ici autour de la table
professionnel chacun dans nos registres
différents effectivement on voit des
points d'amélioration mais c'est le but
et donc c'est réussi parce qu'on a
trouvé des points d'amélioration
justement ça n'était jamais que la
deuxième fois depuis que drum existe
qu'on se faisait des championnats du
monde la prochaine grande échéance ce
sont les Jeux Olympiques c'est quand
même extraordinaire donc on sait
maintenant qu'on est confiant pour les
jeux les observateurs de Paris 2024
était là aussi bien sûr pense ces
championnats vous savez ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont dit ils ont noté je vais pas
entrer en détail mais globalement ils
étaient satisfaits de voir que un tous
ici nous connaissons notre Vélodrome et
nous savons de l'opérer ça c'est quelque
chose de très important
qui se prête bien à l'accueil du public
parce que c'est aussi voilà les flux de
public etc les différents flux pardon de
ça s'appelle d'accrédités la presse les
athlètes etc
et ça nous a permis encore de tirer des
enseignements comme à chaque événement
on tire toujours des enseignements d'un
événement donc on en a tiré ça nous
permet de nous améliorer pour l'avenir
avec ce soit sur la participation des
bénévoles que ce soit sur les moyens
technologiques que ce soit pour les
athlètes voilà il y a toujours des
points d'amélioration mais des beaux
championnats du monde des médailles
françaises la France qui gagne le
vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui rayonne la
technologie en France qui se développe
et qui rayonne aussi c'est voilà des
premières mondiales c'est quand même
quelque chose d'absolument
extraordinaire il y avait un consortium
de partenaires tous plus importants les
uns que les autres dans la dans la
technologie avec des expériences
innovantes aussi bien pour les
professionnels que pour le public donc
c'était vraiment très intéressant et
réussi Patrick Shab qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez sur plan sportif c'était
vraiment la fête à bon moi j'étais oui
on a parlé beaucoup de l'organisation
mais sur le plan sportifs par contre
c'est vrai que quand on est au milieu
d'une organisation on voit toujours de
l'intérieur et petites imperfections ça
c'est clair après il y a aussi d'autres
choses là qui qui perdurent c'est
le fait qu'il n'y ait il y a un problème
de mise à disposition d'une restauration
pour les visiteurs ça a été déçu et ben
il y a des gens moi j'étais à l'accueil
à la création et les gens ils posent la
question mais où peut-on déjeuner pas se
restaurer quand on voit que la buvette
elle ou à 17h alors que ça vient se
terminer
pareil c'est un axe
c'est toujours un axe d'amélioration
c'est compliqué là il y a un choix
l'organisateur effectivement qui se
discute
c'est toujours compliqué moi je me
souviens 2015 par exemple au plus haut
du plan Vigipirate qu'on se faisait
sympathiquement houspiller par les
spectateurs parce qu'on leur interdit
d'entrer des bouteilles par exemple mais
pour des raisons de sécurité sont les
forces de l'ordre qui nous l'imposent
donc voilà il y a des axes qui sont
toujours un peu compliqués qui peuvent
toujours s'améliorer j'ai aucun doute
sur le fait qu'en 2024 et pendant les
jeux il y a tout ce qu'il faut dans le
vélo de Rome à proximité du Vélodrome et
que le parcours spectateur soit jalonné
de points pour acheter à boire et à
manger avec tous les partenaires des
jeux aucune inquiétude sur ce sujet
voilà effectivement il y a ces points là
c'est pas c'est il faut bien comprendre
que un événement comme celui-là c'est
beaucoup de gens de professionnels de
partenaires de bénévoles qui viennent
s'agréger pour étant donné finalement
très court et il faut que tout ça
s'imbrick et fonctionne parfaitement
dans un temps donné qui est très très
court après des mois et des mois de
préparation mais
on se prépare finalement chacun dans son
coin et d'un coup le jour J il attaque
il faut tout un brique et que ça marche
parfaitement donc c'est pas si simple et
ça marche alors oui surtout de
l'intérieur on trouve toujours des
choses par rapport à faire mieux mais ça
marche ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut c'est
important ce que dit Arnaud mais il y a
deux positions qu'on peut avoir la nôtre
parce qu'on était les acteurs sur place
et téléspectateurs il a pas toute cette
conscience de de petites années mais
qu'est-ce qui reste en vrai c'est le
sport c'est le scénario du sport et
justement le sport qu'est-ce qu'on va
qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir est-ce que
c'est un test réussi pour au niveau
sportif je parle bien sportif vous qui
êtes au monsieur SkyTeam vous savez ce
que c'est
pour mes coureurs c'est
mitigé avec un type de champion de
championne du monde de Clara Coconi
championne du monde 30 secondes après il
y est plus c'est la loi du sport
avec des appréciations des juges avec
voilà avec l'intelligence des Allemands
pour l'équipe de l'équipe de pour la
vitesse par équipe
avec malheureusement un faux départ des
Allemands je pense un peu provoqué oui
qui fait partie timigidon et Vigier
quand on ne pas de coup de coude
pétards
et après ils sont deux le temps de
récupération est faible ils reprennent
et on s'aperçoit que tous les deux après
ne font pas un bon temps en raison de ce
de cet état de cause ça c'est la
première chose c'est deuxièmement
troisième élément quand on va l'équipe
de France de poursuites par équipe avec
Quentin lafar qui est qui faisait de la
vitesse et qui se reconvertit comme
endurant lanceur de l'équipe de France
de poursuite qui est dans le coup
et
ici concours de circonstances
la Petite Pierre
d'engrenage va pas bien et puis on se
disloque un peu dans le collectif ce qui
est dommage parce que c'est l'équipe moi
je pense qu'elle a de la valeur tout ça
c'est une histoire
on voit Mathilde qui est championne du
monde oui c'est peut-être mal
peut-être le titre le plus marquant de
ces championnats du monde
c'est cette histoire de résultat cette
histoire de sportif voilà
l'organisation
est importante j'imagine
d'un coca à la Muette qu'est-ce qu'il
veut lui des émotions de mon petit écran
justement quel est votre plus grosse
émotion sur ces Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste Régis peut-être moi
j'ai vu la finale du Madison j'ai adoré
et il est français ils l'ont géré
tellement ils ont été qui ont été
exceptionnels je trouve qu'il ils ont
été intelligents de comment ils sont ils
sont placés dans dans le coton de tête
sans jamais trop et puis à un moment
donné ils nous fournit l'effort où il
fallait ils l'ont tué le Game et puis
après terminer le petit rattrapable et
ça ils l'ont été exceptionnels et ça ça
crée une ambiance de folie avec un grand
Benjamin Thomas qui est arrivé sur une
jambe je crois Thierry Fabre il voulait
pas spécialement
vous voulez participer à cette vidéo
c'est un pro et le on rigole également
parce qu'on se connaît bien mais le
cycliste et toujours quelqu'un qui se
cache bien
il devrait jamais ses plans quand on dit
pas en forme c'est que c'est pas vrai
quand tu dis je suis en forme c'est
qu'on est pas bien
il vaut mieux pas être en forme et voilà
quoi
très tactique
c'est un sport très tactique tactique on
l'a vu avec cette histoire de faux
départ tu es ok la tactique est partout
il y a voilà il y a une guerre
psychologique aussi donc voilà c'est
ça et Benoît du coup vous votre meilleur
moment peut-être c'est mon duo je crois
que c'est vraiment la ferveur
j'ai pas du tout suivi je m'en excuse
mais parce que j'ai pas là on avait
beaucoup de choses à gérer mais c'est
vrai que c'est l'affaire vert dans le
stade c'est on savait déjà quand les
Français étaient sur la piste donc ça
comme dans tous les sports mais là
particulièrement c'était très intense et
non j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un public
partager connaisseur aussi et toute
génération ce qui m'a fait vraiment
plaisir donc moi mon meilleur moment
c'est que une famille entière puisse
participer au mondiaux et viennent en
famille en plus de toute région je crois
que j'ai pas les les listes des
personnes qui étaient venues en général
dans les comptes rendus mais je j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait quand même pas mal
de de locaux et moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis
de voisins qui étaient au courant de
bien évidemment de cet événement qui qui
ont souhaité y participer et qui ont
adoré
surtout la combativité de Mathilde
Legros et de
la hargne qu'elle mettait dans dans le
ça vous a impressionné ah oui les deux
mais c'est en fait c'est elles sont
explosives et puis elles sont lâchées à
la fin
ça Cruse émotions
le père de Marie divine les tribune
maintenant
il me dit eh ben quand on est entraîné
par le meilleur on devient le meilleur
oui
bien sûr
et ça c'est une certitude parce qu'il a
tellement eu de palmarès et puis il a un
feeling que il les a transcendés
ça se voyait elles étaient transcendées
le meilleur moment le meilleur moment
mais juste avant par rapport à ce que tu
viens de dire il faut jamais oublier que
le sport est même quand c'est une
performance individuelle à la fin c'est
un travail d'équipe il y a une équipe
derrière chaque sportif individuelle et
on n'arrive pas à ce niveau là si on
n'est pas soutenu cadré accompagné
pousser voilà donc vraiment et c'est le
message qu'il faut faire passer aux plus
jeunes le sport c'est l'esprit d'équipe
moi le meilleur moment c'est la victoire
de Mathilde parce que ce titre il est
plus que mérité qu'elle l'attendait
qu'elle le gagne à la maison devant son
public devant sa famille dans son pays
on l'a vu arriver à la Fédée on l'a vu
progresser donc voilà c'est c'est vous
l'avez vu toute petite Mathilde si je
peux dire
j'étais comme tout le monde et heureux
ému vraiment je l'ai croisé il y a pas
longtemps je lui ai dit le plus
simplement du monde en remerciant pour
pendant pour les émotions comme nous a
donné parce que c'était une victoire
extraordinaire vraiment magnifique donc
ça restera un beau souvenir pour les
téléspectateurs et spectateurs du
Vélodrome national de saint-quentin-en-y
c'est mondiaux oui oui je pense on l'a
dit un ambiance est folle dans le
vélodrome sur un événement comme ça on
fait plein de choses dans Vélodrome
national plein d'événements mais ça
reste un vélo de Rome il est fait pour
le cyclisme sur piste et quand on a un
événement international et que le
vélodrome est plein il y a une ambiance
fantastique si vous deviez donner une
note peut-être pour pour terminer sur
cette thématique des Mondiaux note sur
ces Mondiaux peut-être Régis SARL sur 10
sur 10
et demi
neufs
[Musique]
mais autrement sur l'aspect ambiance
c'était super Thierry alors vous vous
êtes
des spectateurs sur 10 12
la problématique je vais faire un
parallèle juste deux secondes sur le
rugby lorsqu'on fait la mêlée sur le
rugby avec nos caméras avec du dessus
avec la déformation de mêlée ben c'est
vrai qu'en tant que l'équipe de France
ensuite on est allé directement chez les
entraînements c'est la première fois
qu'on arrivait à voir cette déformation
vu du dessus et voilà et donc pour nous
c'est très important de travailler avec
les coach sportifs et de la présentation
pour justement ce que ce que ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure c'est c'est cette
émotion qui est ressentie nous on doit
la transmettre mais pour la transmettre
il faut qu'on s'y on est la connaissance
du sport et pour ça il faut qu'on puisse
l'intérêt vous avez vu et vous avez vu
les caméras qui étaient sur les vélos on
était en immersion totale c'est-à-dire
qu'on était dans la course nous la
caméra qu'on a mis aérienne au dessus
c'est pareil on avait une proximité très
importante donc ce que je veux juste
expliquer c'est que les spectateurs et
les téléspectateurs vont être de plus en
plus d'acteurs de la vision qui vont
pouvoir ressentir sur les sur sur toutes
ces événements parce qu'on va être on va
leur donner la main ils vont avoir la
capacité de réaliser eux-mêmes leurs
propres images avec les caméras qu'on va
mettre à disposition donc voilà c'est
juste pour dire que cette répétition
près olympique parce que c'est sur des
chaque mondiaux en général interviennent
juste avant les les jeux permet
justement de faire toutes ces
corrections et pour nous professionnelle
et nous rencontrer et de discuter pour
être encore plus fort sur les jeux c'est
pour ça que c'est important
dans le sport c'est important mais cette
réussite de cette année nous l'avait peu
on l'avait peu vu avant parce que le
spectacle commence dès le début quand tu
vois que maintenant avec les caméras les
cadres la technique ou la technologie
qu'on a quand tu vois que sur vitesse
chaque fille Mathilde
toutes les filles même les pista c'est
leur regard cette confrontation de se
regarder
des images voilà ça c'est des choses
qu'on avait pas avant
quand je voyais timigeon avec son casque
timboussert avec l'équipe soyez la
concentration des trois gars de l'équipe
de France les d'un concentration des
Allemands on a pris une mesure
supplémentaire par rapport au dernier
Jeux Olympiques parce que toute cette
qualité d'image et de caméra
le spectateur il est acteur maintenant
c'est ça qui a changé et c'est sur cette
évolution là qu'il faut aller pour que
tout le monde puisse vivre encore plus
c'est ce qu'on n'avait pas avant
Olivier Mozart qui est un grand
spécialiste de la discipline qui couvre
vraiment voilà il a il a vraiment voulu
pousser techniquement pour justement
faire une démonstration sur cet
événement technologique pour savoir pour
être prêt pour les jeux pour se dire ok
j'ai vu j'ai vu jusqu'au bout pouviez
aller maintenant on va travailler et on
va encore affiner mais voilà on avait
donc on a eu quand même une tout le
monde a une bonne pression et des très
grands professionnels avec qui
travaillent lui aussi en tant
qu'opérateur je sais pas si vous avez vu
celui qui est au milieu de la piste qui
fait justement ces gros plans et qui
tourne nicote en permanence dans la zone
bon voilà c'est c'est un très très bon
opérateur donc c'est juste pour voilà
préciser aussi que le réalisateur a un
rôle important sur sur l'écriture on va
passer maintenant notre prochaine
thématique on va parler des bénévoles
les Championnats du monde de cyclisme
survie se sont donc déroulés pendant 5
jours de national de 50 ans Olivier un
événement qui a réuni des centaines de
bénévoles du territoire parmi eux deux
retraités de Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui
s'appelle Jean-Paul on regarde le
reportage il fait partie des 250
bénévoles retenus pendant ces mondiaux
sur piste 2022 à 73 ans Jean-Paul de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux aide les
spectateurs à trouver leur place pendant
ce rendez-vous il a commencé le
bénévolat sur les événements sportifs
des Yvelines depuis une dizaine d'années
qu'est-ce qui me plaît déjà l'événement
lui-même le fait de pouvoir apporter
quelque chose aux sportif et le fait de
rencontrer beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
monde et dans un contexte comme celui-ci
des gens du monde entier comme je parle
anglais ça me permet aussi de dialoguer
d'échanger avec des gens d'un peu
partout son ami Jean-Paul lui aussi
originaire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
dans l'air central pendant la
compétition ce retraiter badge les
journalistes présents sur ces Mondiaux
les Villois a commencé le bénévolat en
1989 il est aujourd'hui sur sa première
grosse compétition internationale
j'adore ça faire plaisir aux gens
transmettre et puis il faut bénévole
partout
j'étais arbitre de foot sans arbitre
même amateur il y a pas de match
il faut des bénévoles sur les sorties
scolaires surtout c'est gratifiant quand
même de sentir utile on devrait revoir
ces deux Jean-Paul en 2024 sur les
différents sites ivoirs retenus pour les
Jeux Olympiques de Paris ils ont reçu la
bonne nouvelle la semaine dernière ils
sont pour l'instant sur la liste des
bénévoles de l'événement
Patrick Chab super reportage avec les
deux Jean-Paul vous les connaissez bien
c'est deux tempéraments différents c'est
clair mais ils sont toujours présents en
fonction de leur dispo bien sûr oui
évidemment et donc on a vu Jean-Paul II
parce que pour moi reconnaître Jean-Paul
qui est Jean-Paul
Jean-Paul II hein
polonaise donc facile à retenir
avec un petit peu d'histoire et
autrement ils sont extra mais là encore
je
[Musique]
notamment Jean-Paul II et qui parle
anglais là on n'a pas su l'exploiter au
niveau du festival peut-être qu'à la
place où il était il arrêtait peut-être
plus opérationnel et peut-être ça va
donner une dimension plus comment dire
[Musique]
plus professionnel il parle très bien
anglais et donc il faut l'utiliser à la
bonne place ce sera peut-être celui pour
les Jeux Olympiques peut-être après
c'est un problème de oui mais
de là il y a beaucoup de bénévoles qui
sont embarqués dans la dans les JO mais
il préfère travailler sur 50 ans
alors la question sur cette sur cette
thématique est-ce les bénévoles sont-ils
un maillon essentiel pour le bon
fonctionnement d'un événement planétaire
comme celui des JO de 2024
en dehors de ça donc on continue les
villes haute vous savez donc dans toutes
les villes il y a des bénévoles partout
donc à Montigny il y A 330 bénévoles
aussi qui sont qui ont été choisis et
qui sont qui sont actifs aussi de la
même manière donc ils ont été il y en a
certains qui ont reçu du Kojo déjà leur
leur participation alors sélection
d'autres pas donc on a des fois on a eu
on a le cas d'un couple qui a eu le
monsieur est pas le COJO pas Madame donc
c'est on sait pas pourquoi donc c'est
pas de chance donc voilà donc après ils
sont actifs toute l'année dans tous les
événements qui se passent sur Montigny
donc voilà en fait
pour aider à la réussite de l'événement
tout le monde a gagné les bénévoles qui
veulent participer en festif et puis
l'organisateur
les élus donc c'est pour nous c'est
notre mission
ce programme bénévole pour les JO 2024
alors d'abord ce qui est important c'est
et Jean-Paul l'a dit dans le reportage
s'il y avait pas de bénévoles de sport
il y aurait plus d'événements il se
passerait plus rien
les deux
un chiffre ce sera plein pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 le comité
d'organisation de jeux olympiques et
paralympiques recrutent 45000 bénévoles
c'est énorme pas de bénévole pas de
sport plus de match plus de sorties des
enfants plus d'événements économiquement
ça ne serait pas tenable donc évidemment
c'est essentiel on a la chance à 50 ans
en Yvelines dans les 12 communes de
l'agglomération d'avoir beaucoup de
bénévoles des gens impliqués on se
connaît tous avec le temps présent sur
tous les événements on n'a pas le temps
de lancer un appel à bénévole ils sont
déjà là donc c'est merveilleux alors
pour les jeux comment ça se passe en
fait il y a un process officiel pour
candidater pour être bénévole mais le
comité d'organisation nous a sollicité
nous les collectivités hautes pour nous
demander de les accompagner et de faire
en quelque sorte une présélection de
bénévoles qu'on leur a transmis on leur
a tout simplement transmis les noms des
bénévoles avec lesquels on a l'habitude
de travailler parce qu'on les connaît
parce qu'on sait qu'ils sont fiables
digne de confiance et que ce sont des
bénévoles
professionnels plus facile finalement
d'être bénévole sur les JO quand on a
été bénévole plusieurs fois c'est plus
facile ou les environs c'est plus facile
tout simplement parce que nous on
atteste du fait que ces bénévoles là
savent ce qu'ils font savent de quoi ils
parlent sont à l'heure ne sont ne s'en
vont pas en milieu de journée enfin
voilà sophiables ils sont fiables tout
simplement et et après je rajouterais
juste un message important parce que la
condition pour être bénévole à Paris
2024 il y en a qu'une seule c'est d'être
majeur au 1er janvier 2024 donc le
message que je veux faire passer c'est
au plus jeune à ceux qui seront majeurs
cette année-là leur dire inscrivez-vous
tentez votre chance c'est extraordinaire
dans sa vie d'avoir la chance d'être à
l'intérieur certainement comme celui-là
c'est dans votre pays c'est près de chez
vous il faut être libre au moins 10
jours donner 10 jours de votre temps
pour pour participer à ça parce que vous
ne le ferez peut-être qu'une fois dans
votre vie et c'est je pense que ça
marque est-ce qu'il reste des places
que les 45000 bénévoles ne sont pas
encore regrets
dans le bénévolat de des Jeux Olympiques
il y en a qui vont être ramasseurs de
balle à Roland-Garros il y en a d'autres
qui vont être qui vont accompagner des
présidents de fédération internationales
d'autres qui vont être au pied des
podium pour les athlètes pour les
cérémonies d'autres qui vont être
trouvés d'autres qui vont être à la
cantine des Athènes il y a plein plein
de missions donc voilà c'est une
opportunité fantastique de vivre les
jeux de l'Intérieur qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez des bénévoles alors moi j'ai
je reviens sur la Chine parce que on a
vécu quand même une situation sans trop
de bénévoles sur place et donc on a
vraiment sentiment
très peu de public voire pas du tout
public et donc on était quand même dans
une bulle très particulière et pourquoi
je dis ça parce que
l'arrivée dans un pays étranger sur les
jeux c'est pratiquement le premier
accueil
non non je parle d'hiver
et donc du coup on a véritablement eu ce
sentiment d'arriver dans un pays où vous
avez besoin d'avoir cet accueil vous
avez besoin et c'est vrai que ce sourire
il y a une vraie motivation de recevoir
et voilà c'est ce que j'apprécie plus
chez bénévolat c'est cette transmission
de passion qui est que tout le monde a
et le plaisir de recevoir les bénévoles
sont là par plaisir et par passion donc
ça se communique naturellement Thierry
et le covid ça a tué des clubs parce que
moi aujourd'hui comme d'autres clubs en
Île-de-France on trouve plus de
bénévoles aujourd'hui je regarde
j'achète des nouvelles de Versailles je
regarde les sports sur Rambouillet pour
parier pour Paris-Brest Paris
il manque 600 bénévoles aujourd'hui
et c'est au mois d'août ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que on n'a pas encore
pris le pas du bénévolat parce que
l'histoire de covid mais la chance avec
les Jeux Olympiques ça va dynamiser le
bénévolat
et ça va redonner de l'amour à donner
pour les autres c'est la chance qu'on a
parce que si on enlève les jeux
aujourd'hui le bénévolat il est terminé
allez moi j'organise le championnat du
dauphin de cyclo-cross j'ai 105
adhérents
et bien tout le monde travaille j'ai peu
de salariés il faut que j'appelle
Patrick non mais voilà parce qu'on
travaille ensemble mais Patrick qui
vient avec si bénévoles de mardi
mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi dimanche
et ben qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe le tissu associatif
c'est la base de la réussite pour tout
le monde
sans bénévoles je dirais ça c'est plus
profond parce qu'en fait souvent les les
clubs sportifs pensent premièrement à la
compétition et aux entraînements ils
oublient de se structurer ils oublient
de s'entourer de bénévoles quel qu'il
soit et donc parce qu'en fait des
bénévoles il y en a mais on ne sait pas
qu'ils existent c'est ça le problème et
ce qu'on a
commencé mutualisation regarde
maintenant et bien on se mutualise moi
quand je fais une organisation quand le
club de Rambouillet a besoin d'un coup
de main je vais des Rambouillet quand
Rambouillet embrouiller vers moi quand
lui es semer trop transport il vient
m'aider par exemple mais voilà on est
obligé de fédérer nos forces pour
pouvoir organiser maintenant ça sera le
mot de la fin sur cette thématique on va
maintenant parler de course à pied un
thème qui va sûrement vous faire plaisir
à nos courtiers la course à pied vous
connaissez très bien alors vous qui êtes
un passionné de course à pied vous savez
sans doute qu'il y aura un marathon un
marathon pour JO de Paris en 2024 il
passeront parler Yvelines pour nous en
dire un petit peu plus vous qui avez
suivi le dossier par Versailles Viroflay
qui sortira sur l'ouest dans les
Yvelines qui montera dans les Yvelines à
prendre redescendre au marathon qui ne
sera absolument pas plat donc il ne faut
pas s'attendre avant
positif de 436 mètres un dénivelé
négatif de 438 m l'inclinaison maximale
sur la route sera de 13,5% c'est pas mal
c'est beaucoup c'est c'est vraiment
beaucoup je rappelle qu'on sera au mois
d'août il va faire chaud donc voilà donc
effectivement pour un marathon c'est un
petit peu exceptionnel donc on verra pas
de record de olympique ou du monde battu
sur la sur la distance
impossible par contre on va avoir belles
images c'est un tracé historique il est
lié à l'histoire de France
il va permettre aux téléspectateurs du
monde entier de découvrir Paris et
s'approche banlieue sur une fois encore
sur un axe historique et c'est aussi une
volonté je pense du comité
d'organisation de plusieurs niveaux axes
historiques c'est la marge des femmes
sur Versailles le 5 octobre 17
neuf exactement un épisode clé de la
Révolution française la marche des
femmes et l'une des premières
manifestations de l'histoire 5000 à 7000
femmes sont venues chercher le Roi à
Versailles pour le ramener à Paris
exactement alors là durant le marathon
des sportifs bien sûr et puis là encore
une nouveauté des jeux de paris 204 le
marathon pour tous un marathon fait pour
les gens comme vous et moi qui ne sont
pas des grands athlètes mais qui aiment
la course à pied vous avez de ça ou pas
j'espère le gagner puisqu'il faut le
gagner ce dossard on ne peut pas
l'acheter il y aura 20000 24 dossards
pour participer il faut s'inscrire au
club Paris 2024 faire du sport marquer
des points et espérer tirer au sort pour
avoir son dossard qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez moi la course à pied
de la manière dont on en parle c'est
c'est fabuleux moi je trouve qu'on
reprend quelque chose d'historique on
prend quelque chose c'est
qu'on est
il y a un symbolique finalement dans
tous ces JO 2024 par exemple j'ai eu la
chance de vivre ce que j'appelle
on a tous les plus beaux jeux quoi qu'il
arrive mais c'est les Jeux d'Athènes
parce que c'est le perso c'est le
berceau de l'Olympique j'ai eu la chance
j'avais été avant à Athènes en tant que
valide j'avais parcouru le Stade
olympique j'ai fait les jeux et après je
suis retourné en tant qu'on dit et j'ai
aussi fait le jeux olympiques comme ça
j'ai fait la boucle mais je trouve ça
fabuleux non non c'est le marathon c'est
ben c'est la base c'est la base même du
des jeux pratiquement qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez moi d'un point de vue visuel
je pense que ça va être assez
intéressant parce que j'ai découvert le
château de Versailles Château de
Versailles j'ai découvert plusieurs
marathons de Paris et c'est vrai que là
on va sortir un petit peu du
traditionnel des traditionnels images
donc je trouve que effectivement ce
dénivelé est intéressant aussi
parce que moi j'ai fait la caméra
principale
du des premiers qui courent et je peux
vous dire déjà sur le plat il y a une
souffrance qui est quand même assez
importante on les voit très souvent et
là j'imagine que ça va être assez dur
justement dû aussi à la chaleur donc je
pense que ce marathon va être très
intéressant d'un point de vue visuel
justement et bien sûr au niveau de la
course ça va être assez technique je
pense
moi je pense aux
on en parle pas trop les JO P mais
tu pourras nous dire aussi comment ça se
passe mais quand je vois une balle
croûte
fantastique ce qu'ils font les gars
c'est fantastique alors ok circuit va
être défini qu'est-ce qui a fait
qu'est-ce que tu as des infos Arnaud
est-ce que tu as quelque chose donc
voilà quoi aujourd'hui
on parlait tout à l'heure des jeux mais
on va être bénévolat et ben ça s'arrête
pas qu'aux Jeux Olympiques il faut
continuer jusqu'à la récompense c'est
les deux
moi je me suis mis sur bénévole sur les
deux
et voilà faut pas faut penser aux goup
parce que quand on voit les championnats
du monde qui a eu à Saint-Quentin il y
en a eu des médailles des français quand
même plus que les valides
en fait parce qu'il y a eu un problème
de communication
c'était un peu de gueule à tout à
l'heure
tu es un public conquis mais il y en
avait pas beaucoup par rapport
si on allait seulement sur le site du
Vélodrome ça apparu que le samedi le
samedi seulement sur le site du vélo
mais c'est normal et avant moi je suis
en plus à la communication de la Ville
de Montigny on n'a pas été informé alors
c'était pas le même canal c'est pas le
même organisation effectivement c'était
pas les mêmes organisateurs donc là là
c'est même le mouvement du sport qui est
un peu responsable du truc qui a pas
fait son boulot et puis lui je pense que
Lucie aussi parce que il aurait dû
communiquer bien avant bien un événement
comme ça on doit communiquer sur les
deux événements en même temps est-ce que
je pense moi par exemple je me suis
battu beaucoup sur 2012 on voulait que
les Jeux paralympiques soient avant les
Jeux Olympiques parce que souvent il y a
une montée en puissance religieux et
puis après obser descend pour les
prochains qui auront lieu en 208 à Los
Angeles ça sera le cas ce sera la
première fois je partage totalement les
parents
la lumière c'est toujours avant ouais
c'est toujours avant une fois que vous
éteint la lumière faut la rallumer les
paravent et on n'éteint pas la flamme
entre les deux voilà simplement
on va maintenant passer à une nouvelle
thématique quand on pense Jo 2024 on
pense forcément sportif et ils sont
plusieurs dans les Yvelines à pouvoir
briller en 2024 je vous propose de
découvrir les têtes d'affiches
potentiellement médaillable et vous
allez me dire à chaque fois si oui ou
non elles peuvent reporter une médaille
à votre avis alors on va commencer par
un basketteur une mesure de mettre 21 je
sais pas
si vous connaissez Victor webmadiamine
mesure de mettre 21 il était médaillé
d'argent européen chez les U16 au
Mondial chez les U19 et joue aujourd'hui
chez l'équipe de France A il a ici
réussi à marquer 20 points pour ce
premier match avec les Bleus il joue
chez les métropolitanes 92 Victor
webmania ma est-ce que ce garçon qui est
du Chesnay Rocancourt peut remporter une
médaille avec l'équipe de France de
basket et bien
vous le connaissez bien Patrick Chaves
beaucoup il va pas rester longtemps en
France
normalement l'année prochaine il est en
NBA
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous à
Benoît dans ton médaillard aussi
remporter une médaille effectivement je
crois que là il a une ascension
il est très très regardé par certains
international et je pense que voilà
c'est pas que les atouts physiques c'est
aussi dans la tête ça se passe il est
très jeune je sais plus quel âge a 18
ans 18 ans
au mois de juin
sportifs sur le tennis et sur ce sport
de plus en plus jeunes
moi j'ai j'ai vécu pas mal de Jo et il y
a eu des découvertes comme ça sur des
jeunes athlètes qui sont arrivés très
vite aux médailles donc oui je pense
qu'il a vraiment aujourd'hui sportifs
[Musique]
c'était un extraterrestre
tous les temps en NBA régisseur
individualité de 3 mais si l'équipe elle
est il y a un point faible donc j'en
sais rien c'est il faut que tout le
monde soit à peu près équivalent c'est
ça la difficulté
parce que dans sa tête il n'y est
peut-être
mais pas tout à fait ça va dépendre d'un
équilibre son équilibre de sportif avec
son encadrement et son équipe familiale
s'il y a un des deux qui va pas ça
bascule soit d'un côté soit l'autre il
faut toujours rester droit dans ses
valeurs et c'est ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter et qui réussissent on a
l'exemple de Mbappé et on disait qu'il
va pas aller loin même Mbappé ça fait
cinq ou six ans qu'il est déjà
performant
si voilà on parlera justement un peu
après
on a parlé du fait qu'il part peut-être
un billet moi je lui souhaite pour sa
carrière et parce que aller jouer dans
le meilleur championnat du monde c'est
pour lui avant les Jeux la meilleure
opportunité justement de faire cette
apprentissage du plus haut niveau de
l'esprit d'équipe de bénéficier
d'encadrement professionnel exceptionnel
qui lui donneront certainement ce qui
lui manque peut-être aujourd'hui parce
qu'il est jeune tout simplement qu'il a
encore à apprendre forcément mais oui
bien sûr voilà aussi de bonnes chances
de médaille en cyclisme sur piste je
pense notamment à Mathilde de gros elle
a 23 ans elle est tout juste championne
du monde de vitesse individuelle elle
est double champion d'Europe du kering
multiple championne de France Mathilde
de gros on l'a on la présente plus
médaillable ou pas sur ces jeux de paris
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
et puis je pense qu'elle a pris par ces
compétitions c'est mon Dieu on a pris
une nouvelle dimension
au niveau de
confirmé moi je suis confiant elle a
passé un cap
et la France
[Rires]
bien sûr en tout cas on lui souhaite et
après on verra bien parce qu'il reste 2
ans pour aller au jeu c'est à la fois
court et long et puis il y a une vraie
concurrence mais oui aujourd'hui elle a
parfaitement tout le potentiel pour être
médaille dangereux
mais c'est long les deux ans
la dernière année elle est chaude on
arrive il faut il faut être prêt au
moment c'est tous les quatre ans les
jeux c'est ça le truc
aussi après une victoire comme celle-là
elle a fait la une de l'équipe est-ce
qu'elle va réussir à garder cette tête
froide oui parce que elle est bien elle
est bien entourée elle est bien encadrée
c'est ce que tu disais tout à l'heure il
faut des familles côté staff etc et
c'est ce qui va l'aider à garder la tête
froide exactement
les peu de choses que j'ai pu voir dans
les Mondiaux c'est justement cette
ambiance et ce groupe équipe française
ou justement ils étaient très solidaires
et ils se sont vraiment mutuellement
aider j'ai l'impression avant pendant et
sur la course donc je pense que c'est ça
qui est important aussi c'est pas se
sentir seul on parlait d'équipe mais
voilà on est sur la piste on est aussi
avec tous ces ces acolytes qui qui vous
aident tout le monde les coachent tout
le monde donc je pense que oui il faut
voilà il faut y croire aller la France
donc ce qu'il faut surtout c'est parce
qu'en fait la différence se fait un
point de vue mental de hargne sur ce
type de compétition une autre sportive
qui peut peut-être aussi performer c'est
claracoponique vous connaissez très bien
à Thierry Fabre et au BCE Sky type
boussair potentiellement médaillable
faire accompagner moi j'y crois parce
que la chance va tourner elle passe à
chaque fois les championnats
moi je pense que elle a un sacré
potentiel et puis alors
elle est forte moralement elle est très
forte c'est ce qu'elle veut elle est
intelligente je la vois qu'elle quand
elle ça se voit le positionnement
ça fait penser un peu à Thomas Bouddha
quand je la vois sur son vélo et les
pieds calés elle est bien concentrée le
petit renard du skateing vous sert
vous avez été conquis aussi vous la
connaissez bien
mais je la connais mais je sais que
enfin je partage tout ce que tu viens de
dire parce que voilà elle travaille
les capacités pour physique
intellectuelle donc ça va sourire et les
jeux à la maison ça donne envie de se
dépasser voilà à la maison et sur ces
terres de club exactement en plus bonne
chance
tout juste championne du monde du 500
mètres champion de France 2021 et 2022
on l'a vu en interview elle a aussi
énormément de fraîcheur cette Marie
divine qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez Patrick
chihabara puis au moins elle expressive
et ça c'est bien c'est la vraie sportive
elle est assez jeune oui elle est jeune
bon on verra après ce que ça va devenir
mais en fait
son tempérament et ça c'est bien
Benoît qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
maryline.be est-ce que vous avez pu voir
sa finale non malheureusement mais je
vais
la chance de pouvoir des replays de tes
blagues bien sûr j'ai toutes les images
donc j'ai de quoi regarder toute cette
immersion mais c'est vrai je reviens ce
que je disais tout à l'heure je crois
que ce groupe est formidable et puis que
effectivement la terre sur lequel ils
ont poussé avant leur permettre de
gagner plein de médailles je leur
souhaite le plus vivement possible on a
aussi un cavalier je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est Victor l'évêque
cavalier internationale étoile montante
de l'équitation c'est un cavalier de
concours complet il a grandi dans les
Yvelines et est installé depuis peu à
Maisons-Laffitte il aura 26 ans en 2024
il fait partie des gros potentiels
français est-ce que c'est un jeune
garçon ah je sais pas si vous le
connaissez mais est-ce que c'est un
jeune garçon aussi à pousser peut-être
pour pour une médaille olympique il est
jeune on sait qu'en équitation on arrive
généralement à maturité un peu plus tard
Régis arène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
sinon c'est une chance mais c'est vrai
que
c'est peut-être un peu jeune après des
expériences fait il y a plein de sport
comme ça maintenant on s'aperçoit par
exemple si vous prenez un cas un
Caroline Garcia par exemple et qui qui
en train d'exploser maintenant avec
l'expérience avant tennis on avait que
des jeunes joueurs bon chez les valides
en ce moment et les jeunes joueurs sont
exceptionnels donc mais là chez les
Français on a toujours tendance à
exposer un peu plus tard je sais pas
pourquoi il faut d'expérience il faut
quelque chose peut-être que de notre
école n'était pas bonne j'en sais rien
il y avait quelque chose mais là
l'exceptionnel donc là sur l'équitation
c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut beaucoup
d'expérience moi je tiens du vieux un
peu du monde du cheval parce que je
viens de la Normandie là donc c'est là
où la terre de cheval dirait et donne la
Manche surtout et c'est vrai que les
gens qui sont dans le cheval et ben ils
l'ont acquérir une expérience avec le
temps il faut parce que là ils sont deux
aussi et le cheval aussi c'est un couple
on a l'habitude de voir
cavalier les cavalières une certaine
expérience
néanmoins
autorisons-nous
pourquoi pas parce que le talent parce
que l'envie parce que à domicile parce
que ça va être dans un cadre
d'équitation absolument
exceptionnels
donc pourquoi pas être transcendé parce
que c'est ce premier jeu parce que c'est
à la maison parce que parce que c'est
dans un castor exceptionnel parce que il
vous porte il peut se passer quelque
chose il faut juste que l'émotion soit
pas trop forte
maîtriser c'est peut-être la jeunesse
c'est peut-être la jeunesse qui va
malheureusement c'est peut-être là où
l'expérience parlons en général enfin il
y a un footballeur je pense qu'on
connaît tous sur sur ce plateau qu'il y
a le Mbappé il aura il aura dans deux
ans de plus du coup là en 2024 il a
évolué à Clairefontaine dans les
Yvelines entre 2011 et 2013 il évolue au
Paris Saint-Germain depuis 2017 il veut
jouer ses JO de 2024 il aura 25 ans à
peu près peut-il remporter une médaille
c'est un petit peu la même chose qu'avec
webmail sera pas seul sur le terrain
mais c'est un événement en tout cas qui
peut potentiellement remporter une
médaille Thierry Fabre vous en parlez
tout à l'heure mais
le sport collectif j'ai pas une chose
une chose exacte une science exacte
c'est ça le problème c'est que
apporter quelque chose
un peu spéciale pour le pour le football
les réservés aux joueurs U23 de moins de
23 ans et on peut sélectionner trois
joueurs de plus de 23 ans
donc ce qui va dépendre c'est la
richesse de notre formation jusqu'à 12
jusqu'à 2 ans dans 2 ans si les clubs
pro arrivent à sortir des jeunes
en 23 avec un fort niveau et qui sont
pro aussi c'est à très bien mais où il
faut s'interroger c'est l'équipe
nationale
[Musique]
des jeunes qu'on disait avant espoir
elle fait pas tellement beaucoup de
résultats concrets en ce moment donc ce
travail aussi là dessus je pense que
tout ce qui est mur par la place par la
fidélité ça va bien ça va bien
fonctionner et avec l'encadrement
technique qu'ils ont à Clairefontaine je
pense que ça va marcher parce que il y a
toujours que des Arnaud on est à la
maison quoi la motivation elle est
différente l'implication elle est
différente la pression des spectateurs
elle est différente
moi je me souviens sur une coupe du
monde j'ai des copains qui étaient pro
qui vont parler et bien quand ils
partent les Clairefontaine
quand ils étaient escortés par 6 motards
ils avaient déjà la pression
ça commence là parce que comme on dit
toujours oui ça se gagne un match
mais ça se gagne dans le couloir avant
droit
très rapidement parce qu'il nous reste
même pas 30 secondes 30 secondes à
rapidement ce qu'on est en train de se
dire c'est que nous on fait des prises
d'image on transmet cette émotion et
c'est vrai que de travailler ensemble au
niveau sportif et mise en images c'est
essentiel pour retransmettre cette
émotion maintenant moi j'ai vécu pas mal
de Jo effectivement avec pas mal de
jeunes sportifs
qui ont démarré et je crois que cette
motivation va avoir la connaître d'ici
la fin de l'année aussi parce que en
fonction de ce qui va se passer mois
prochain ce mois-ci le mois prochain
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
Apple là d'antan vous avez conclu par
votre entreprise ils disent des motion
qui sera sûrement sur ses Jo 2024
alors c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose une citation de Pierre de
Coubertin le fondateur des Jeux
Olympiques modernes le succès n'est pas
un but mais un moyen de viser plus haut
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]